Wesley this was just an incredible match
and yeah I want to start with this game
because this was just wild and we were
looking at the camera your hands were
trembling at some point did you feel
your heart pumping
yeah for sure thank God there's no heart
rate monitor
but thank you yeah thank Christian for
you always cheer me up whenever you come
here that's good that's good talk to us
about this game
your I mean on the back foot somewhere
around here and objectively in fact you
are lost yeah yeah did you think that
you were lost at this yeah
I mean I thought I was drawing but then
he kept kicking my kick making farther
and farther away in fact I was just
discussing with Fabiano just before
coming here
um we're trying to find a win for white
after Bishop E1 so this was the critical
win yeah
H4 and now this is some sort of a study
like Chuck why a king G4 if you go King
G4 then I can go King C6 and I have the
pin on the eighth round
and if I don't go to G4 then you get
checkmated
yeah check made it if you go here I go
here it's crazy yeah but it's simply
crazy yeah I mean I should have
taking the door early on I think white
was winning on move 92 even from other
moves yeah like like white house all the
time in the world yeah but uh ah look at
fate
maybe is winning as well but still you
managed to survive in this one and after
that you took over in the last game
tomorrow you will be facing in fact
Fabiano Carona yeah how do you feel
about that matchup uh well it's going to
be an a very exciting match I hope I can
put my Beth chest you know uh Fabian of
a wonderful and great player the
defending U.S Champion so hopefully
it'll be all right I mean it's hard to
predict what's gonna happen
and uh yeah today I felt a bit tired
because I just came back from Berlin but
put in some 14 hours of sleep
and then come with a lot of energy is
that the best way to fight jet lag yes
sleep as much as possible yeah I mean I
take melatonin okay
we did not no yeah yeah she offered was
in Berlin but I mean yeah probably a lot
of sleeping taking naps and try to come
with the full energy but I'm very
pleased to to win the day everyone if
the treasure Wesley congratulations
we'll see you tomorrow thank you very
much indeed our congratulations is
Wesley as well Wesley